hey this is actually very interesting
news ex-white house counsel lawyer Don
McGann will have to testify behind
closed doors about Donald Trump's
efforts to obstruct the Russia
investigation now again I know that
whenever this comes up some some portion
of the audience will say David you've
fallen for this conspiracy or that
conspiracy or whatever the case may be
I'm not falling for anything I don't
think this will lead to any
repercussions for Donald Trump trump is
out of office the ship has sailed the
Russia probe was never going to uh
result in Trump being charged or removed
or anything like that but Don McGann is
a guy who as White House counsel was
privy to all sorts of relevant actions
uh by Donald Trump and who has been
ignoring and avoiding Congressional
subpoenas for a really long time uh it
has now been determined that he indeed
is going to have to testify
um Don McGann will testify before the
house Judiciary Committee yes behind
closed stores about Donald Trump's
attempt to obstruct the Russia probe the
house and the justice department have
announced this in a court filing
Wednesday night why a court filing if
it's a testimony that will take place
behind closed doors for a political body
because he had been ignoring the
subpoena
the interview is going to happen quote
as soon as possible there will be a
transcript released so we will know the
substance CNN reports that the committee
members who interview McGann can ask him
about the incidents documented in the
Mueller report of Donald Trump's
attempts to fire Robert Mueller to block
the Russia investigation and about the
accuracy of that investigation the
justice department can assert executive
privilege or McGann can decline to
answer on other topics that will prevent
house Democrats from learning uh details
about other trump-era scandals which is
too bad but this is still better than
nothing and this is a major concession
from the executive branch because for
years the Trump Administration was
trying to block exactly this from
happening and uh this became something
that went into court because
because of the degree to which Don
McGann was just being obstinate on it
and we are now going to get at least
some information so it's been a two-year
standoff it went to court it's now over
Democrats wanted Don McGann to testify
he's going to testify but it will be
behind closed doors there will be a
transcript and the topics that are
acceptable for which he will be forced
to answer have been outlined and they
are the conclusions of the Mueller
investigation Trump trying to obstruct
the investigation and fire Mueller and
the uh accuracy they're in but beyond
that Don McGann can say not going to
answer not going to answer my
expectation is Democrats will try on
some of those other topics
knowing that Don McGann is going to
decline to answer merely to get that on
the record although in transcript form
it's definitely less interesting or
dramatic than in video form and I look
forward to reading very much about this
if you
um are skeptical that it will lead to
anything I'm right there with you I am
not reporting this to you as wow look at
this bombshell we're about to hear all
these unbelievable things from Don no no
no I understand that that's not going to
be the case please don't come back to me
in six months and say but David uh you
were saying that the Don McGann
testimony was going to be some kind of
Blockbuster of him no I'm just curious
to see what he says it's a great thing
that he wasn't able to fully avoid this
it's been a two-year Court battle and it
is ultimately going to be going to court
and that's a very going to uh Court
decided he will have to testify and I
look forward to seeing what he says and
how evasive he is and we'll see what
happens beyond that Monday a memorial
day we will be doing a single day
membership special just one day
if you've been thinking maybe I'll get a
membership someday if you've been
thinking maybe I'll use one of those
coupon codes Monday Memorial Day is the
day to do it okay it will be a one day
membership special if you want to be
notified just get on my newsletter you
can do that at davidpackman.com sign up
for the newsletter Monday Memorial day
you'll get an email and it will tell you
exactly how to take advantage of this
coupon code as well as exactly what that
coupon code is all right let me know
what stories you're watching find me on
Twitter at dpacman we have a it's just
like a packed program today we may
oftentimes after these shows are done we
just delete the files when we don't feel
very good about the show a lot of
deletions have taken place we're keeping
Today's Show archived because it's bound
to be a very good one we'll be right
back after this if you are anything like
me you probably aren't thrilled with the
idea of going into a doctor's office
right now and thankfully there's a
practice vehicle and affordable way to
take control of your health and get
personalized care from the comfort of
your home it's a service called steady
MD they're one of our sponsors you take
a quiz you get matched with a licensed
primary care physician who understands
your health needs you have a one hour
video call with your new doctor you
establish a meaningful relationship with
them and after that your doctor is
available to you anytime by text phone
or video chat this is not a random
doctor on call each doctor at steady MD
has a limited number of patients so they
actually have time to listen to you you
get the personal attention that you
deserve they can do almost everything an
in-person doctor can do perform medical
evaluations talk to you about health
concerns send prescriptions to your home
or local pharmacy and anything they
can't do online they'll quickly set you
up with an in-person provider to do
things like blood tests as an example
you don't need insurance it's only 99
bucks a month with no other fees or
co-pays there are so many practical
advantages to using steady MD for
Primary Care and it's also so much more
affordable go to steadymd.com Pacman to
take the free quiz see which doctor is
right for you I took their quiz they
matched me with a doctor who specializes
in my particular Health needs and
situation the doctor they gave me is a
really perfect fit for me and my medical
needs there's no risk no commitment to
get started just click the link right
underneath this video